hello everyone uh hello everyone online
thank you for being here uh so today uh
uh thank you for the introduction john i
am an industry assistant professor
at new york university
uh in the integrated design and media
program that's part of tandon the tannin
school of engineering i'm also part of
our the ability project which
bridges the gap between technology and
disabilities
so
again very happy to be here with you all
today
so i want to first start with the story
um pokemon go
how many people in here have played
pokemon go or out there a bunch of you
have played okay so
in 2016 i was working near
central park
and i went out for lunch and during my
lunch i saw a huge crowd of people
running
like running and i said what is going on
i live in new york city people a big
group of people are running
is there a problem
and
the
there were a few people who weren't
running and so i said excuse me
what is happening and they said oh we're
playing pokemon
and i
i said
what so that was my first introduction
to pokemon
and i've played a little bit and
i get the pleasure of teaching a class
called looking forward and uh looking
forward is a class where we gus chalkies
and i
teach students about the assistive
technologies that blind and low vision
folks use
and gus and i were talking and i
mentioned to him uh you know playing
pokemon
and gus is blind
and when i mentioned to gus you know
what pokemon was and i was describing it
for those who don't know does anybody in
here want to describe it because i
always like to ask
who who are my pokemon go players
come on
no one wants to describe it
[Music]
yeah so it has a real life map
it's using augmented reality right and
you use it to you catch things right
and so i was describing to
uh gus the game and how you play and
he said i wish i could play
and i thought
why can't he play because he's blind he
can't
that that made no sense to me and so one
of the things that i decided to do
this was right before i was going to
teach a summer class i said i'm going to
have my students work on a project
to create a concept for
an augmented reality experience for
someone who is blind
and so my students worked with gus and
they also got to work with people in the
blind community and they came up with
several different concepts so this is my
story of telling you how i got
interested in accessibility and
inclusion in the space of
xr
so i want to first start with some terms
we should all get familiar with
the first one is accessibility some of
you may know what accessibility is some
of you may not
accessibility is the concept of whether
a product or service can be used by
everyone
however they encounter it accessibility
laws exist to aid people with
disabilities but designers should try to
accommodate all potential users in many
contexts of use anyway
to do this has firm benefits notably
better designs for all
next is inclusion now you'll hear me say
this description uh but uh
really don't leave people out i don't
know how else to say it
we have defined uh this is from ocad
university we have defined inclusion
design as design that considers the full
range of human diversity with respect to
ability
language
culture
gender
age and other forms of human difference
and xr so xr is stands for extended
reality it's shorthand for a related set
of technologies
that are changing the way we interact
with the world
and with each other so this is virtual
reality augmented reality and mixed
reality
next is ableism this is a very important
term for folks to know and understand
because it is at the root of so many
things that are broken
ableism is discrimination and social
prejudice against people with
disabilities or who are perceived to
have disabilities
ableism characterizes persons as defined
by their disabilities
and as inferior to the non-disabled
able ableism is systematic the
institutional devaluing of bodies and
minds deemed deviant abnormal defective
subhuman less than ableism is violence
so questions to ask as you're working on
things are
do you include people with disabilities
in your design process
are your design solutions intended to be
used by your future self
does your product promote an inclusive
language
next is assumptions uh we all have them
right there our inferences and ideas are
often based on assumptions that we
haven't thought about critically
a critical thinker is attentive to
assumptions because they are sometimes
incorrect or misguided
so questions to ask yourself are
what are your assumptions about the
people and context that you are
researching
have you double checked the truth of
your assumptions
next is bias
bias is disproportionate weight in favor
of or against one thing
person or group compared with another
usually in a way to be considered unfair
self-correction against implicit or
unconscious bias takes a lot of
conscious work
so question is have you acknowledged
your biases and try to counter them by
trying to understand the perspective of
others
next is justice social justice so social
justice is concerned with the just
relationship between individuals in
their society
often considering how privileges
opportunities and wealth ought to be
distributed among individuals
question to ask is
how can you use your design concept to
advance a social justice agenda
marginalization so marginalization is a
process where something or someone is
pushed to the edge of a group
and is treated as insignificant or
peripheral
so questions to ask are how does your
design disrupt the marginalization of
people
if you work with marginalized groups how
will you ensure that the work is
developed from their perspective
and not your own
self-awareness i cannot stress this
enough for designers i encourage it to
my students
so much to know yourself it is so
important
self-awareness is having a clear
perception of your personality
including strengths
weaknesses
thoughts
beliefs
motivations and emotions
self-awareness allows you to understand
how other people perceive you
your attitude and your responses to them
in the moment
question to ask is
how can you become self-aware enough to
realize how self-aware you are not
transformative research transformative
research is a synonym for emancipatory
research
it is a research framework that centers
the experiences of marginalized
communities
including analysis of power
differentials that have led to
marginalization
links research findings to actions
intended to mitigate disparities
and has an agenda for change question to
ask is
how is your work transformative
unlearning oppression
some everyday practices seem normal and
go unquestioned but discriminate against
minorities
many well-intended people are unaware
that their actions are oppressive
oppression affects both the oppressed
and the oppressor
to unlearn oppression we must
acknowledge our everyday oppressive
practices
and engage in critical self-reflection
with the aim of becoming actively
anti-oppressive
so what will you do to unlearn
oppressive behaviors
and you
you
play an active role in change and
transformation
you have the agency to question what is
happening around you
and take action as a response
design may be one form of response
so question is
what are the attitudes needed
to be a
to be a manager
change agent facilitator or researcher
this is a great set of cards here i have
an image on the left hand side of a set
of cards
from dr leslie ann noll
called the designers critical alphabet
it is pretty amazing i would recommend
this for every designer to have
in their toolkit
have you tried vr
by raise of hands
who has tried vr in the room
a majority of people in the room have
tried vr however
97.81
of the world hasn't tried vr yet
yes
uh a lot of people haven't tried it this
is the truth
and there are many reasons for that
uh
so many reasons for this but this is
from um pablo pablo cardenas and uh he
did a talk for
uh a11y vr meetup and and talked about
this in depth
have you tried ar augmented reality has
anybody tried ar sometimes people don't
know they've tried ar because
filters anybody ever do use a filter for
anything yes filters on your instagram
yep bunch of you so yeah the truth is a
lot a lot more people have tried uh ar
so
this uh here i have a chart of uh the
number of mobile augmented reality
active users worldwide from 2019 to 2024
and these numbers are in billions so
in 2019 it was 0.44 in 2020
0.6 in 2021 0.8
in 2022
is that the year we're in i can't
remember this pandemic is missing
in 2022 uh 1.07
billion people
this is estimated in 2023 1.4 billion
and in 2024
uh
1.73 billion
how many people are in the world
nobody knows
[Laughter]
i think it's about
do you know
i think it is about seven billion so
yeah
so currently xr is being used with
artificial intelligence
assistive technology
business and retail communication
education empathy entertainment and
recreation events
gaming
health and rehabilitation meetings
navigation
therapy
training video programming virtual
assistants and wayfinding
does anybody use
ar or vr for things other than
entertainment in here
you do
you um it for research
okay yeah so research and entertainment
is what the room demographic is okay
cool
so i wanted to touch on artificial
intelligence and accessible xr so
artificial intelligence and machine
learning are crucial tools in making
extended reality a more realistic
opportunity for everyone for example
it's easier for software to track things
like gestures and eye movements through
intelligent systems which could make
augmented and mixed reality environments
more immersive
however there are gaps
with artificial intelligence extended
reality and accessibility so
those who have borne discrimination in
the past
are most at risk of harm from bias and
exclusionary ai in the present
and when these discriminate
discriminatory logics are reproduced and
amplified by ai systems
they are likely to be read as
authoritative
the product of sophisticated technology
beyond biased data additional risks are
presented by this by the significant
power asymmetries between those with the
resources to design and deploy ai
systems
and those who are classified
ranked and assessed by these systems
the history of disability itself can be
read as a story of the ways in which
various systems of classification
i.e medical scientific legal
interface with social institutions and
their articulations
this is to say that
ai oftentimes doesn't
capture a disability as it should
and if we're relying on this technology
you're either disabled or non-disabled
and if you're not disabled you will be
at some point because that's life
and if there's an ai that is determining
your disability or not i don't know if
we really want that so
these are things that we have to
get more informed about and get more
involved with
right because we don't want ai totally
determining everything for our lives
and this is from meredith whitaker and
team
at the ai now institute at miu
so there are some
accessibility challenges with xr
accessibility is often an afterthought
that's just straight up real
how many of you make stuff in here
how many of you incorporate
accessibility
be honest
right it's an afterthought or not a
thought
um so some of the the challenges with xr
is that controllers
require both hands right
inputs and outputs of experiences don't
offer
accessibility options
affordances and usability do not account
for people with disabilities
depending on the medium and this is
especially with ar 90
of an environment can cannot be
controlled
experience depends on bodies being in a
certain position in order to move
and experiences are based on audio or
visual alone
so the w3c has some guidance some things
designers and authors need to be aware
of understanding specific diverse user
needs and how they relate to xr
successfully identifying modality needs
that are not obvious but still need to
be supported
suitable authoring tools that support
accessibility requirements do i have any
developers in the house
none
okay i'm gonna bore some people later
with some stuff i'll just maybe go
through it and i can send you the slides
using languages platforms and engines
that support accessibility semantics
providing accessible alternatives for
content and interaction
the provisions of specific commands
within the vr environment so for example
to go to directly to a specified
location
or to
follow another user which assists the
navigation to support different
modalities
and the use of virtual assistive
technologies for example a white cane
via a haptic device to provide
non-visual feedback
so the research identified that if the
same audio cues associated with real
world
infrared white cane were used in an
immersive environment
users were able to effectively center
themselves in the middle of pathways
and walk successfully through virtual
doorways based on the same audio
feedback
as used in the equivalent real world
device
so here are some of the w3 people here
familiar with w3c
no
[Laughter]
okay so i'll just i'll just start this
uh w3c
is a world wide web consortium
everybody who works on the web should
know about the w3c
if you do anything web related you
should know about the w3c go google them
they
are
not they are the international standard
uh they have put forth the web content
accessibility guidelines
and such they have also put out some xr
user needs and requirements so i'm going
to go over some of those
here are some of the the xr user needs
and requirements
uh immersive semantics and customization
motion agnostic interactions
immersive personalization
interaction and target customization
voice commands
color changes
magnification context and resetting
critical messaging and alerts
gestural interfaces and interactions
signing videos and text description
transformation
safe harbor controls
immersive time limits
orientation and navigation
second screen devices
interaction speed
avoiding sickness triggers
spatial audio tracks and alternatives
spatial orientation mono audio option
captioning subtitling and text
with support and customization
why is accessibility in xr important
it's the right thing to do
period
it really is
so
i'm going to ask the people in this room
to answer me
if you're paying
attention when you think of someone who
uses vr or ar who do you think of
can you please describe them to me
i will call on people thank you thank
you
i think of someone because i'm not i
think of someone who's young
and active and
very tech savvy
somebody who's young and active and tech
anyone else
yes i think of those videos of like this
25 year old guy like walking around a
room like bumping into things you know
like
the kind of like
um stereotypical like six foot tall
white male okay so a six foot tall 25
year old white male who's in a big
enough space to like walk around and
bump into things that's who you're
picturing for vr
anyone else picturing that
person yeah kind of
mark zuckerberg
[Laughter]
but in that space okay mark zuckerberg
type yeah yes
basically that but 14 years old okay so
14 year old
maybe not as six feet tall but
also white male yes okay yes back here i
think maybe some like anti-social
some anti-social people
okay
gamer types what's a gamer type
i need like someone who likes video
games somebody anybody who likes video
games
okay
yeah so this is very interesting to me
because uh just a few weeks ago i was
working with my grad research assistants
and i asked those questions you know
designers focus
on human-centered design but which
humans are we actually focusing on
are we focusing on the non-binary
person
who is
45 years old
in a wheelchair
whose
has low vision
the answer is no
and why aren't we is the question i'm
asking to you all
as creators designers developers
which humans are we actually focusing on
and does the focus need to continually
be
the 25 year old or the 14 year old white
guy
because that's what we we we think about
when we think about a gamer
and we need to flip that and really
start to think about the real humans
that actually use the stuff we produce
so i have a video
and i didn't practice this i hope this
video goes but i want to introduce you
all to walk in vr which is a
it's a cool thing i'll talk about a
little bit after but this video runs
about three and a half minutes
will the sound go through
okay let's just hope this doesn't blast
people away it's too loud
it can be an amazing thing
it gives people the opportunity to
experience things they wouldn't
otherwise be able to like flying or
traveling through space as well as more
down-to-earth activities such as getting
a good workout
it's not quite so easy for everyone
though
with virtual reality or
vr we use real world movements to
control your actions in the virtual
world
this is a big part of what makes it so
immersive
but what happens when your real world
movements are limited as a result of
disability
it means that some vr games and
experiences is simply not an option for
you
for example a game may require you to
turn around but if you use a wheelchair
that's not so easy
some disabilities mean you can't grip
things firmly so you may not be able to
hold the controllers at all or have
problems using the buttons
thankfully there's a solution
walking vr is software that allows you
to adapt a vr environment so that
limitations in your movement don't have
to mean limitations in gameplay it works
on the steam platform and integrates
with the steamvr environment meaning it
can be used successfully with almost any
game let's look at four ways walkingvr
can adapt virtual reality
the first is a feature called virtual
movement
this is helpful for when you can't walk
but you can move your hands and hold a
controller
to use it you simply grab space with a
button and then move or turn around
with a condition like spinal muscular
atrophy you might be able to hold the
controllers but not maintain them at the
height required by the game
in this situation the position
adaptation feature can help
this allows you to adjust the position
in which the controller needs to be held
to one that's more comfortable
in the simplest case this would mean
changing the height but there are more
advanced options too like using rotation
or the distance the controller is from
your body
the boost feature amplifies your
physical gestures
this means small movements in the real
world translate to much larger ones in
the vr environment it can get easier to
pick up or throw virtual items
this can be particularly helpful if you
have a limited range of hand or arm
movements
another feature is the ability to set
different parameters for each hand
this can be helpful where one hand or
arm is weaker than the other for those
that have had a stroke say
this feature means you can compensate
for the weaker arm enabling you to bring
the virtual hand up into your field of
vision something that can have a
positive psychological effect if this is
more than you can manage in the real
world and it's not just a position you
can adjust
some people can move the controls well
enough but have problems with buttons
and other tactile aspects of gameplay
for these people there is the personal
assistant function
this allows another person to assist the
disabled player using a separate game
controller they can make helpful
adjustments to the avatar's position and
also perform button presses making
gameplay easier for the disabled user
there's also a large group of people who
have problems holding controllers those
with some forms of cerebral palsy for
example
attaching the controllers to yourself in
some way can be uncomfortable and they
can be easily dropped
by using walking vr in conjunction with
kinect and potentially other tracking
devices
you can interact with vr environments
without the need for a controller
indeed many games and applications can
be played this way including workout
routines
put together all these features mean you
can finally focus on the whole point of
the exercise
playing the game
virtual reality offers a great way to
have fun work out and try new
experiences we're so excited that we can
now open these possibilities up to a
wider audience we very much welcome and
look forward to your comments and
feedback
so walk in vr is available on steam
and it's adapting vr games for people
with disabilities walk in vr has been
tested to make vr accessible
for people with uh
cerebral palsy spinal cord injury uh
traumatic brain injury muscular
dystrophies spinal muscular atrophies uh
neuropathy and orthopedic problems
on the right i have a an image of the
walk-in vr logo is a person in a
wheelchair holding controllers in each
hand
with arm spread wide
so this is my ongoing research i'm
examining inclusion and accessibility in
the extended reality space
one of the first things i started with
here i have an image of a google sheet
showing names of tools
cost enterprise purpose
accessibility features programming
languages scripting languages supported
platforms
system requirements and features so when
i first said i'm going to research
inclusion and accessibility i didn't
know what i was thinking first of all
that's huge
right so i said where should i start
and i decided to start with the tools
the tools that are used to create
experiences
and so i started looking at
do the tools cost money
do they have certain system requirements
do they require a certain level of
knowledge from someone in order to
um participate so if do i have any unity
users in here yes
a little bit so
for those who don't know unity unity is
created to make games it's also created
to make a lot of virtual reality
experiences and it's really helpful if
you know c sharp
because if you are using unity
hands down you are going to change a
script at some point
and if you don't know
c sharp you're going to have some
trouble and that's a barrier to entry
right
so um
you know i was like this is boring like
who wants to see this spreadsheet nobody
wants to look at the i mean would you
all look i mean right like it's nobody's
looking at this thing
so i uh
working with uh sakiasakawa
we came up with our city right so you
you want to learn about xr but you don't
know how so what do you need a map
right so uh here uh the image is of a
neon sign of xr city uh there's an
opaque subway map with stops at free
game vr
accessibility and ar
so this is what we came up with uh this
was a year ago actually we came up with
the xr city map
and this xr city map uh guides people
and helps them
to determine if they are going to use
what tool when so
i will just read the legend uh there is
a map here which appears to be a subway
map there's a
[Music]
lane for gaming for drawing for ar for
3d frameworks for characters for
prototyping for modeling for animation
and one of the things that was important
for us is are things free or not
because that's again a barrier to entry
um and then is there any sort of
accessibility
documentation related to any of these
tools
out of the 60 plus we looked at how many
do you think had any sort of
accessibility documentation with them
looked at 60 over 60
how many had accessibility documentation
i'm seeing number three i see a lot of
threes
three
three
somebody's saying zero
two
four
four
so
there's a gap there right there's a huge
gap there
um
here i have an animated image on the
right hand side of somebody uh doing vr
with the
worlds around them so in 2020 i joined
vail which is an international research
group who are looking at design patterns
in vr
to examine design patterns in vr and i
expanded on the research by looking
specifically at accessibility in vr
along with
assad mahmoud who is my
[Music]
grad research assistant last summer so
we examined how they perform concerning
accessibility and inclusivity and how
experienced because experiences can
improve them
so
here is an image
description a young black man and a
color colorful colored shirt and blue
pants seated in a wheelchair next to a
white tesla
with the black passenger side falcon
wing door open
motioning towards a spacious interior
which could very easily be utilized to
make a wheelchair accessible vehicle
with an in-floor ramp
how
do you think this person could get into
this vehicle
more importantly why isn't there a ramp
it
adds to the cost it adds to the cost
yes they just didn't think about it they
didn't think about it
yet again they didn't think about it
right so
you know there are some current
challenges right accessibility options
are an afterthought in most cases right
um and this is in reference to vr but
it's also in reference to life
there's real no real focus on
accessibility options there's very
little awareness for challenges faced by
users
and there's limited development tools
available for smaller companies
i want to tell this story real quick i
got asked
someone reached out to me to speak to me
about accessibility in the xr space and
they had made a video
about
accessibility in vr
and i went to watch the video
and the video did not have any captions
which
why why not right that's a huge deal if
you make a video at captions youtube
like automatically has them you can
adjust them
and when i asked this person why did you
not add captions to the video that you
made about accessibility they told me
because it would take too long
what can i say
what can i say except i did say a lot of
things
so
with that
here i i have an a bit of an animation
of the different titles that we tried
for virtual reality any beat saber users
in the house beat saber user yeah boom
boom boom it's a lot of fun so beat
saber uses nav users navigate through an
obstacle course uh with emphasis on the
song being played right um also we tried
waltz of wizard where the user goes
through a maze of different challenges
uh to progress through a story
here my animation continues with the
different types of uh titles we used
we used rec room a collection of user
made rooms that a person can join and
interact with other people
epic roller coasters if anybody has
never tried vr before don't do roller
coasters as your first experience
don't do it
and if you do a roller coaster
please be seated
i'll just say that so the user sits
through various uh
different rollercoaster rides bait is a
fishing simulator and echo vr where a
user plays with other
players in a unique sport in space
so
our what we learned were there were
common issues present in most titles and
the type of accessibility options that
are offered are limited
issues with accessibility options were
physical reactions psychological
reactions
barriers to entry and widespread
adoption and the cost of head-mounted
displays
so here
on the left i have an image of a person
who's pointing with a vr headset on
so the common issues very few
accessibility options
lack of extensive tutorials and some
titles
little flexibility for different play
styles and not friendly for smaller
spaces i live in brooklyn
literally my couch and my refrigerator
are like this close right like
so
um
i don't know who created these games or
what spaces they use but they were not
in a brooklyn apartment because
although with the quest 2 which is what
we use you can create a boundary
um i had to be super careful not to hurt
myself and as a matter of fact i don't
like really doing vr in my apartment
anymore at all
i prefer like my office which has a lot
more space
so
some of the accessibility options are
hand tracking has anyone tried the hand
tracking with a quest 2
it's improving slowly
playing while sitting
playing with one hand haptic feedback
subtitles room scale or stationary
guardian and different locomotion
options
so
hand tracking here i have an image of
hands trying to grab a button so hand
tracking it doesn't allow full control
that a user might have when using a
controller
here i have a person who is sitting on a
couch with a vr headset on looking up
so playing while sitting it's a limited
movement when when trying to play while
sitting and a built in ability to rotate
so a lot of the experiences
if you wanted to sit
it wasn't the best for your game play
i had to throw this stanford cup in here
because i'm here
so for haptic feedback feedback not
accurate to what is happening in the
experience and usage of generic feedback
for most motions
and this is a great resource for those
who are interested in learning more
about vr this is on git github uh this
is called the locomotion vault um
uh i will say this if you have motion
sickness to things that move this might
do something to you because all they
have all these gifts that are moving so
i'll just say that as a warning when you
go into the github
but some options might cause issues for
the the user such as motion sickness
which a lot of people
uh still get with with vr experiences
and this is something that assad pointed
out
that cost is a barrier
so rs here stands for indian rupee on
the left hand side i have a quest two
which is 299 dollars but it's 50 000
rupee in the middle is a vive pro
799
a 132 000 rupee and
on the right hand side is a valve index
it's 999 and 165 000 rupee
so i had a conversation with someone um
in india
a few months back and they had just
ordered a quest to and said it was one
month's salary
so for me that's like well
if everybody's talking about i'm not
going to say the m word but if
everybody's talking about the m word you
all know what the m word is
if everybody's talking about this being
the next big thing is it really because
who is this for
right
um so another thing i'm working on uh
currently is augmented reality
heuristics so our objective is to
evaluate existing experiences for
inclusion and accessibility
highlight and address key gaps and pain
points in
xr in general
understand why these issues are present
and think and create a framework toolkit
guidelines that address current design
solutions and present guidelines for
others to implement readily in their
designs and our deliverables uh we we
hope
uh by the end of this year to have a
frame framework toolkit and guidelines
for inclusive and accessible xr
experiences from a content creator
perspective from a designer and
developer perspective
um and an an actual
example of an accessible experience
so
this uh here on the
right i have two images of using uh
google maps beta version of augmented
reality uh this is near my campus and i
got a group of students
to use this and and get some good
feedback on on what they saw so we're
examining mobile augmented reality uh
specifically and looking to see
what we can use to help content creators
evaluate accessible experiences
and this is another part of my ongoing
research is working with immersive
stories lab africa
in
2020 and i want to make sure i say
fami's name correctly
femi uh
agba
created historius emersas the spanish
language version of the stories lab
which won a journalism 360 degree uh 360
grant from online news
the grant supported historius immersa's
aim to user storytelling to share the
stories of underrepresented groups in
colombia
so immersive story lab africa is working
with libraries librarians
in namibia ghana nigeria uganda and
zimbabwe
we are we
my team are working with them to provide
supplies and support for making
experiences accessible
some stories will be featured in my
upcoming book which i'm writing with
doug northcook titled human spatial
computing which will be coming out next
year
so this is something for everybody to
think about
everything around us has been designed
even systems of inequality
have an opportunity when working on
these technologies to make things a
little bit better
and this is a quote from antoinette
carroll who is an amazing human
so thinking about creating a more
equitable future
how can we make sure that we are
designing inclusive and equitable
outcomes for all
no matter how big or small the decision
this is for each of you to think about
individually
how can we make sure that we are
designing inclusive and equitable
outcomes for all no matter how big or
small the decision
whether you're working on a class
project
or you're working somewhere
so how you can get started start small
define what could be
get involved in groups or organizations
and celebrate the little wins
so
begin learning about the xr space if you
have interest i think everybody should
because it's pretty cool
to get interested in this and look into
organizations such as a11ybr the w3c xr
access pete xr association
so i'm going to cover a few of them oh
first so this is for you back there
because you're my developer
everyone else if you want to take a nap
you might but it's okay so these are
some resource resources from the
microsoft uh for for mike from microsoft
for content creators and developers
so x accessibility these accessibility
apis enable developers to design
set and modify game accessibility
features and information in their game
or vr experience
for example developers can configure
closed caption properties uh the high
contrast mode
and the text edge style developers can
also modify the text that displays on
the speech to text wednesday window
and the position of the speech to text
window
for visual accessibility there's spatial
sound for app developers for windows
xbox and hololens 2
documentation on how to implement
microsoft's platform level solution for
spatial sound support
on xbox windows and hololens 2 enabling
both surround and elevation audio cues
the spatial sound apis within
allow developers to create audio objects
that emit audio from positions in 3d
space
adobe games and dolby atmos dolby site
with a great conceptual documentation on
spatial sound
included are links to dolby atmos
resources
for
www.ise i'm just spelling it out uh fmod
xbox pc and mobile
project acoustics documentation
and tools for wave acoustics engine
that simulates acoustics as sound
travels through 3d environments it's
great for sighted developers designing
audio accessibility in their games
as they can use this technology to see
how the sound in their game travels
and interacts with within game objects
i love what you're paying attention i'm
just focusing on you back there
all right tools
cognitive accessibility so azure voice
text-to-speech service with incredibly
natural sounding uh synthesized voices
that can be implemented into games
azure playfab party overview a low
latency chat and data communication
solution for cross-platform
and cross-device multiplayer games
the voice and text features in party can
be used
as a standalone chat solution
and can provide
accessible communication in games so
playfab party to speak
play fab party speech to text and text
display ux guidelines uh for using
uh guidelines for using uh playfab to
provide accessible speech to text
communication supporting games there's
also a play fab party text to speech say
that five times fast
and text input ux guidelines so
guidelines for using
playfab to provide accessible
text-to-speech communication support in
games
for unity or am i unity unity
so
there's accessibility self assessment
tool which is free
simple tools that add a new window into
unity that allows developers to self
assess how accessible your game is or
your experience is
read speaker which is a plugin with apis
for either
unreal or unity that can add text to
speech capabilities to a game
resources offer free trial and
plug-in installation videos vr tunneling
pro which is also free
it's a vr comfort solution for unity
5.6 and higher and it can be dropped
into almost any project for plug and
play comfort options based on grid and
periphery shrinking while moving and
turning
and here's some unity tools for visual
accessibility so there's ui
accessibility plug-in uap which is also
free
a plug-in for unity that helps
developers make their games more
accessible for players who are blind or
have low vision it also includes a
tutorial video
documentation and support form
seeing vr toolkit it's a set of 14 tools
for unity
that enhance a vr application for people
with low vision
by providing
visual and audio augmentations
there's accessibility
text resizing which is free
it's a one-click four-step lightweight
solution to add in text resizing this
key this is a key accessibility feature
and responsive spatial audio so this is
for immersive gaming
uh free unity plug-in to help developers
build accessibility for gamers without
sight into 3d game environments
did any of you know about these my unity
people no
okay okay cool
all right for unreal any unreal people
in the house
no
okay so
for visual accessibility uh
how to support screen readers guide to
implement screen reader support into the
game
there's accessible realities unreal
plugin to make video games and x are
accessible
for people who are blind or have low
vision
spatial spatialization api references
so unreal classes related to spatial
audio each including references syntax
and more
working with audio in unreal so it's a
resource filled with documentation
developers can use to create immerse
and accessible audio experiences in
their game
spatial audio temple
temple demo level so demo level where
developers can experience how unreal
can create a great spatial audio
experience resource also includes a
guide developers can use when exploring
the level
i'm almost through this but i want to
put it out there in the world
unreal tools so audio and accessibility
how to enable subtitles so guide on how
to enable subtitles into the game
yellow subs machine which is a paid
thing it's not free customizable
subtitle solution for unreal engine 4
covers as many legal and best practice
recommendations as possible
and player requested features such as
toggle toggleable speaker color
displaying the speaker's tone of voice
and more
and unreal tools colorblind
accessibility so there's a colorblind
widget
which helps developers apply colorblind
correction settings to the game window
and uh cognitive
accessibility so readspeaker plug-in
with apis for either unreal or unity
already mentioned this one that can add
speech-to-text capabilities to a game
i made it through that
but i wanted to put that out there in
the world
so for those of you who have interest in
accessibility uh and vr
i recommend checking out the a11y br
meetup
they meet monthly but you can also find
previous meeting pass events on youtube
past events include
designing a participatory workshop with
endear knight
uh haptics for xr with eric vizzoli and
tim stutz and ideas for ally programs in
xr tech companies with bill curtis
davidson i have to ask this does anybody
know what this stands for
a11y
i know you do
you do
okay
anybody who does not know what a11y
stands for okay a majority of this room
which means probably a majority of
people watching this so a11y is a
pneumonium
for accessibility
there are 11 characters between the a
and the y
so
if you have interest in learning more
about accessibility you can look up
hashtag a11y and you could find all
kinds of stuff
the w3c
you all know now you google it and
you'll learn about it right the w3c has
created they created the web content
accessibility guidelines and they're
working on guidelines related to xr
there is xr access which i am a member
of a proud member of it's a community
committed to making virtual augmented
and mixed reality accessible to people
with disabilities
there's a symposium coming up it'll be
virtual this year in june so if you're
interested go to xr access dot org it's
a really wonderful wonderful
organization started by folks at cornell
tech
so they also have this xr accessibility
project so
the xr accessibility project is an
initiative driven by the xr association
and xr access to provide a central place
for developers
and designers i'll say that
to find solutions for creating
accessible code and strategy across
various xr platforms
we were inspired by developers key
players in ensuring that this technology
is accessible
who reported challenges in finding
accessible code snippets so
it features strategies code and
tutorials to solve accessibility
problems across a wide range of
platforms
an index that points to resources all
over the internet organized by platform
validation of resource usability and
functionality
a contribution form for adding
additional resources so if you're
interested
and you're working on stuff you can add
to it to put it out there open source
i want to publicly thank my grad
assistants who i've worked with for the
last few years
caillou lu saki
asakawa
assad mahmoud
blessing amole and lauren chun so thank
you all i appreciate you all so much
and my last question for all of you
is what will you do to make a more
equitable future
anybody care to answer
so we've been really
appreciating more students
finding out about accessibility before
they graduate like offering more classes
on accessibility so they're prepared to
think about that as they go out into the
world to the working world
yeah
anyone else
yes
so i'll just repeat what you said
learning the tools
and so that you can better understand
how to make accessibility moving forward
yeah and frameworks yeah that's great
yes
know what questions to ask
know what questions to ask when you make
things yes
yeah outlines of that and something you
said earlier always asking like who
you're leaving out of the design process
at every stage yeah who are you leaving
out from the very beginning yeah who who
are you excluding from the very
beginning
anyone else
what will you do to make a more
equitable future
i teach this stuff that's what i do
anyone else
no one i'm doing
okay
so this quote from nitsy helps nothing
hustle i'll leave you with so thank you
for whoever's on zoom and said start
small so if you start small
and build on what you have
you can continue to multiply that into
something greater while picking up all
the valuable lessons along the way
from the late great nipsey
yeah
and with that thank you uh if you want
to uh
contact me i'm very active on twitter
at reg underscore i-n-e-e
if you uh want to talk to me or have
questions i'm pretty available you can
reach me i'll be available in the summer
but not in the next few weeks but
rg1508
nyu.edu thank you so much
you